and a lady my girlfriend she's obsessed  with murder shows like dateline forensic  files and she caught me watching like  two seconds of gay porn she flipped out  she was like what the hell is this i was  like will you watch murder  isn't that way worse  he's just two people having sex your  thing's the first commandment that's  even on the list  she was like well do you want to do this  i was like well do you want to kill me  she was like oh shut up i'm just  watching this so i know what to do if i  ever get in that situation i'm like well  maybe that's why i'm watching gay porn  yeah yeah she's like oh that's  ridiculous this is a reenactment well so  is this this guy's not really a real  estate broker